Jeremy Foley, Filmmaker/Actor/Screenwriter: After
we had made the short film actually people kept on
watching it and saying this should
actually be a television series.
Film Courage: It's been what 11 years or so
since you started on this filmmaking journey?
Can you talk about the most amount of effort
that you've put toward making a feature
and what have been the biggest challenges
for you and Sara [Sara O'Reilly].
Jeremy: Yeah I think it's been 10-11 years
since we've really been actively making stuff.
The biggest effort we've put towards a
feature…well I have two two kind of thoughts about
that. The biggest effort we put towards the future
is a script that we had written two years ago
that we called fender bender and it's the road
trip comedy the kind of film that we love.
We had produced a sizzle reel to really give
audiences or prospective investors producers
sort of a visual idea of what the film might
be and I think we'd we've gotten that script
into the hands of a lot of production
companies (a lot of big production companies)
and I’ve got to say all of them passed. There
wasn't one company that was like Oh let's pursue
this. But just the fact that you're getting
them in there we were really excited about that
because that is like a positive sign that people
are liking it enough to start passing it around
like it's not just going to those friends or
you know your your family or whatever but like
it's going to people who are moving the script
farther along and you know I feel like we had
a lot of momentum behind that project and then
of course the pandemic happened and so I think
and not just us I think I think
there were a lot of people who
you know just just lost a little bit of that that
momentum and everything they were building towards
so that was probably the hardest or the most
effort we've been put into a feature so far
another thing that happened to us was
really interesting is that we had made
a couple of years even before that we had made
another short a proof of concept short film
that we were hoping to adapt into a feature
and you know we had the feature script ready
and somebody had found our feature script an
actress had found our feature script you know a
prolific television actress you know had been
around and on shows that we all knew and she
passed it to a producer and they actually
approached us about adapting it into a
television series which is something we've
never done and it's kind of interesting how
these things sort of happen because while we
were after we had made the short film actually
people kept on watching it and saying this should
actually be a television series and Sara and I
were like oh yeah that's a you know that's a
good idea we hadn't really thought about that
but people kept on saying it people kept on saying
it and of course we were kind of locked into that
that you know that that narrow view that no it's
got to be a feature film you know we made it to be
a proof of concept short and now it's got to
be a feature so we'd written it as feature but
then here were two people who wanted again we were
hearing to adapt it into television so we actually
signed a deal with them to adapt this short into
a television series and we spent about a year
working on that and of course you know
as can happen so many times projects
you know even though you're super excited
about them and you you really want them
to go forward and there's a lot of momentum
behind it for whatever reason they they end
up falling through and and things don't always
come to fruition the way you wished they would
but I'm using that example just to illustrate
like you never know how the project is going
to come alive we had written a script wanted
to make it into a feature and then you know
something happened that sort of you know set us
back but we had also had another script that we
wanted to make into a feature and we were making
that into a television series so I think you
don't really know how everything is going to fall
into place always so you just got to be ready to
kind of go wherever you know kind of go with your
best path forward and so going into something new
do you always keep that in the back pocket of like
this this may don't get too excited I want to be
on board and ready but it could fall
through and protecting yourself almost so
protecting yourself is I think absolutely crucial
I think again since I've done this for so long
and since I've seen so many things throughout you
know my career and just the different jobs that
I've done and just different projects
that I've been involved with you know
yes absolutely I think that's crucial that yes be
excited about something and and really want it to
happen and really do everything in your power to
make it happen but you know sometimes things will
fall through and it's just completely out of
your control and and maybe sometimes it's not but
but I think keeping your expectations kind
of in check until I think until you're
I would even say you know this even goes back
to like my time as an actor you know actors can
book a really and this is this has happened to
me this has happened to so many friends that I
know you know you can book something really
amazing and you can shoot the part even you
know you can you can book it and you can be on set
and then when you're watching it you're cut out
you know and I think that same sort of mentality
must apply to the filmmaking side that like
I would never really consider something done
until I'm literally at home watching it or I'm
in a movie theater watching it you know things
always happen you know best intentions I've seen
people and friends make films we were talking
about this earlier sometimes it's taken these
people years but I've seen films that have
really and I've even been involved in films
like that as an actor where people invest
so much time and so much money and the film
never gets released ever people have never seen
it it's sitting on a shelf at somebody's house
you know and it's really unfortunate when when
things like that do happen but they do happen so I
would say it is really crucial and maybe maybe you
know something you should start if people haven't
really worked on it or thought about that really
do kind of get yourself used to just things you
know falling through but everything will run its
course and I think one of the ways I've sort of
started to protect myself from that maybe is to
to we like to have just a couple things going on
you know maybe what's what's the what's the phrase
don't put all your eggs in one basket and I think
for for me and for Sara and for our
production company that's been really
helpful is that you know we're trying to just
have a few things that we're working on so that
if something does fall through you move on to
the next one and you're going with that one
and seeing where that one can go and then
maybe that one will fall through maybe not
and then if so you go into the next one but I
think that's really important but I think you know
yeah when I if someone is just starting
out or or thinking of getting into this
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen you're
gonna you know things things fall through
you don't seem jaded to me how do you keep
yourself upbeat very refreshing I think yeah
not that I'm putting you on the spot or anything
but you seem very upbeat to me yeah I think um
ah yeah how do I do it because it is true like
when when you get so attached to something
it's difficult I mean I do I feel you know when
when when a project does fall through it's like ah
you just feel like you were so you know you were
so close or you you know so many pieces were
falling into place and then this one thing sort of
like sucks the air out of it you know it is it's
it's really it can feel you feel terrible it's
it's you know it's really like deflating and and
you just it's like ugh again but I think you do
have to realize that you know it's it's and kind
of we were talking about this earlier too I mean
it's a career it's like it's a the perseverance
thing and it's kind of like you're in it for the
long haul at least that's how I've always felt and
and I think yeah you just you know it is good
to diversify yourself so you're not putting
all your eggs in one basket so if something falls
through you know that's it that's everything you
know you're out of la you're out of the business
I think you really do need to have a good attitude
and and and just yeah be able to sort of overcome
it and yeah for me I think I think being able to
to have a career and to be able to I should say
something that's helped me has been being able
to just always think about it that way I guess
to think about maintaining a a career not just
you know a one one hit or something
like that and I think yeah lately
it really has felt for me a lot better having
multiple things going on so that if something
does fall through because it will that I
can kind of put my focus on the next thing.
Question For The Viewers: What has stopped
you from making your next big project?